you created an online rapping
competition yeah tell us about that
it's called for bar Friday mm-hm you
know I love music and I've been rapping
since I was 14 years old
and once Instagram made a 15-second
video I told myself you know hey that's
the perfect amount of time say for bars
so I did everything I needed to do so it
can be mine and I threw the idea out
there and you know it's picked up a lot
faster than I thought it would that's
cool can we do a demonstration or
something will be that would be fine
yeah you'd be okay with that
all right I'm gonna lay down a beat I'm
the great and the great I lay down an
amazing I'm an amazing and II will tell
you I'm an incredible human beatbox I
actually I actually won't tell you that
so if I don't like the beat then I'm
gonna say cue the beat and I'm just
gonna go acapella there is no way you
will not like this beat it's not
possible all right
[Applause]
yeah
put that thing in a bucket of Purell
okay you go ahead I won't do nothing for
the money see my love and my passion
quick my heart said I should change
lives and I became an activist my
wardrobe expensive so don't judge me by
my fashion sense coz my road to the top
was Royal Rumble with some savages well
I don't think I could have added
something great to that that was
fantastic
yeah we're inside your side here
you